welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Luis moreno-ocampo the first
prosecutor of the International Criminal
Court and a senior fellow at the Jackson
Institute at Yale University earlier in
his career he worked as a prosecutor in
Argentina he first came to public
attention in 1985 as assistant
prosecutor in the trial of the hunters
this trial was the first since the
Nuremberg trials where senior military
commanders were prosecuted for mass
killings today we talk with mr. Moreno
Ocampo about his work with the ICC
welcome mr. Moreno Ocampo thank you for
coming here in 2003 you became the first
prosecutor of the newly created ICC for
those not familiar with it give us an
overview of it and the reason for it
it's the International Criminal Court is
like new member but permanent okay so in
fact you know was a landmark you
remember the first time that the
prosecutors were representing not the
country
Jackson was representing humanity
against the Nazi crimes and it was the
beginning and the idea was to establish
something permanent in particular to
control genocide because in 1948 it
Genocide Convention adopted and
requested to have a permanent a National
Criminal Court
however the Cold War stopped therefore
no agreement the end of the Cold War
create a new moment and the Balkans war
and the horror of people in
concentration camps that people was
singing oh my god this is Nancy again
made that in 1993 the United Nations
Security Council created a new
international Crematory unified us Lobby
okay and this Romina Milosevic was
persecuted and now karateka melodical
there and that was the newer back for a
special case next year 1984 Rwanda
genocide 1 million people killed with
machetes so they were cannot acknowledge
they will ignore the crime but then okay
they had to something with the
perpetrators and they created this new
Tribunal for want and it create the
momentum and then in 1998 there was a
conference at Rome to debate it's a new
permanent call could be created I was
incredibly complicated because worth
five weeks people four hundred sixty
countries debating and they were forty
had an issue to debate it was a project
with 1,400 different topics to debate
Wow at the last day there was a yes or
no boat and honey 20 countries say yes
and seven including US and China if I'll
say no but the Convention was adopted
and the convention required 60 state
ratifying the treaty and in 2002 ten
state ratified treaty and made more than
sixty and then became operational and
therefore in 2003 the state were looking
for prosecuting one persecutor and
eighteen judges okay in those days were
78 state from all over the world mostly
Europe Latin America and Africa they
were the basic contingencies and in
those it was very happy at Harvard
teaching there was a busy professor
there I I was working a cantina for many
years and then suddenly they offer me in
this practice position I was so happy
and then they call me and they say you
would put your name in the list of
candidates to eat the cheap prosecutor
now your name is in the top but we don't
know if you like the job I was in they
will never do it
and so on June 16 2003 with my first day
as ice I was my swinging of this at the
hey in a beautiful piece balance done by
Carnegie in the Netherlands in the
Netherlands yes and I had six floors
empty to employees eighteen judges
waiting for my cases motion attend she
was pretty few you with me because I was
thinking was bad for the us because us
can be posted and they were thinking
could be a free prosecutor prosecuting
bad cases so that was my job
impossible job in fact when I was at
Harvard one of my colleagues told me
Lewis
it's a great honor to be the prosecutor
but you had to refuse it I said why
don't I do the fusing you say a shame
for you imagine will be without us
support
you cannot investigate you can't arrest
people so basically you you would be
nine years at The Hague doing nothing
and receiving a salary that was his
prediction so I think ok I just find my
way to move these cases and so we start
with some cases in Uganda and Congo
Joseph Kony was my first lady now corn
is famous because they've video Kony
2012 and suddenly their food became a
big deal and the commission of inquiry
requested UN appointed a commission of
inquiry to basically crimes they
concluded the double-crank committee
that should be mitigated and the Boojum
intercepted and in the Security Council
refer the situation of Darfur to us so
suddenly we are not someone so much
enemies we became aligned we starting
with together full and we keep emetic
leading in Kenya in Ivory Coast and it
was in 2011 when the Libya Cades arrived
the Security Council by consensus of
this time all the boats fitting both
China us in the everyone
adopted the idea to refer the case to us
so one of my life case it was Gaddafi
and then we did also the for embassy of
Cote d'Ivoire
and then now I left in 2012 so say the
corner has treat my office the office of
the prosecutor has the new particularly
fatou Bensouda
from Gambia Africa and she has 200
people working in different countries
mitigations and try them so what what
would be the teeth of the ICC I mean how
do you actually bring the people to the
court to be judged I mean do because we
work with countries to make that happen
how much in the US with no FBI no
further government but the court
Washington and then you crimes and when
California is not doing his job you
investigate in California and then
United States addressing them so that
way we did Congress some people Belgium
marries someone else friends are with
someone else so some of them are
difficult to raise Kony difficult to
read because it's surrounded by a
militia but Bashir still the pressure of
Sudan difficult arrest Gadhafi was
executed killed but his son is in jail
and we are discussing who should where
should be him prosecuting at the hague
Aden Libya so at the other day we get
our plane we'll get our criminals my
prediction of my friend from Harvard was
wrong we we were working and suddenly so
basically now the world is less
primitive they work as a permanent court
and ready to intervene when there are
massive atrocities and we are
automatically working in countries who
are members or court which are today a
hundred twenty two states from all over
the world in bourbon SEC and in the
country which are not like a star fool
Sudan or Libyan the Security Council can
refer the case to us so that's the model
so basically my feeling is the world is
evolving
they were harris-perry them now so in
the nine years that you were the
prosecutor for the ICC what do you think
is one of your proudest moments
he therefore it was a crisis each day
was we have a crazy in the morning and
other cats in the afternoon was fun it
was impossible because we have to
investigating impossible places we have
to investigate that food without going
to a fool when when they Libya case we
will feel if if we are fast and would
pressure the Gaddafi people would
understand they and they had no future
had to surrender so and that happened in
fact so we push them and some of them
status ran and some generals were
calling us so he's not just putting
people in court the court is playing the
role in deterring crimes and that for me
was the most complicated and interesting
job so I also whatever you decide there
are 1 million opinion different than
your opinion so everyone besides you
whatever you do what would you say is
your biggest regret then no it's amazing
I was scared but I was really difficult
job I had no regret by the way I'm I
learned to be a year now because being
the icy prosecutor was doing something
completely new I had as you did I should
have been the basic what is that how is
working no understand that and the Adem
is not yet understanding that that's why
I loved to be at the L know check with I
like that too because in law school but
I like to be the Jackson in truth
because it not just a matter of law is a
matter of how they diplomats the
political leaders the Army's dealing
with these conflicts so that's why I
have to be in a place where not just
lawyer army guys intelligent people
diplomat politicians when it integrate
ICC but also yesterday and I was for me
it's great to be here because I was in
this new center on network analysis and
I was delighted because they were
explaining network helped to put
together pieces science normally is
segmenting information so you you are
specialists in little things and never
will help you to see the big picture and
that's right
yes and we need that in our field so
what do you think are the greatest
challenges that the ICC faces I mean it
is relatively new so I think it's renew
by the Chinese noticing the change the
world we are living look when I was at
Harvard I'm sorry to say I was a carver
okay the guy who invented Facebook was
their launch in Facebook and it's funny
because people are impressed because
faith who now has more than 1 billion
clients you know how many cities
citizens from different countries are
under a CC 2.2 billion 340 million so we
are the way we grew fastest than
Facebook but in any case Facebook is
showing you is a new world where you
have a we are living in physical space
but also in particularly young
generation living in virtual world is
Luca technologies really made the world
much smaller combining but the problem
is were united by technology by divided
by political institutions we are still
relying in national states and we need
national states but the problem is for
in the criminality is global organized
crime is global and we are not
understanding this problem so that's why
for me Isis is not just about the
channel sector on work which are very
important only to understand how to deal
with them but also normal organized
crime
let me explain I was starting my first
case in Congo and then I was reading a
report that the militia from Congo was
buying weapons to Ukrainian mafia so in
a day hey there is beautiful all the
police you can put it together so I went
there to check what I knew about the
cranium mafia selling weapons in Congo
and the German guy was in charge of the
Europe all told me we know everything
about Ukrainian mafia but we had no idea
that they were working in Africa
because we are not covering Africa we
are just covering Europe so the gradient
mafia is working around the world but
who Europe all with the biggest police
organization is controlling Europe and
that's the problem is impossible to
control them so you need a global police
worse I don't think we'd be a globally
for they could not stay will accept that
because state are reluctant to but we
need to bend something new and ICC is
the new solution because you don't need
we don't I don't need a global police I
could work with local police's but I can
do it during mitigations and that's for
me either trick well developed I say so
phatu obon Sudha became the prosecutor
in 2012 if you could offer her any
advice what would it be
no no they had to be right okay nine
years is enough Ocampa for them no no
she's making her own decision oh no what
but I mean anything that you learned
with me she was made deputy for eight
years so she was involved I think that
way from me I hope so relax because I
really make a big effort to be there and
work but part the biggest achievement
for me was to build an institution so
the fact that is someone who will
represent me who honest who understand
very well what happened so she's
changing things because she got to do it
but she understand the path so say we're
doing that so no idle spectator
independence she called me and sometimes
occasional she called me I had to help
but if not she had to be free of me but
it's very important because it's funny
when I was pursued happen that all
almost all my cases are in Africa so
when group is a good Bashir but she was
abusing of the colonial idea oh I am
African you are against Africans okay
when the Africans a killer and the
beacons are African I care about the
victims but interestingly your
colleagues the journalists normally are
following this Bashir
four years ago when my sister was at the
inn that is about the colonial African
my of the ICC I was thinking is crazy
it's a genocide how they can ignore the
genocide so but she convince people that
this is not about the educational side
who now no one talked about genocide
that food and he still annoying is about
the freaking thing and that's why
fathers now the new face and it's great
is much more institutional it no more
one person is and G from Africa so when
I was going to say since she is from
Africa do you think that might help a
little bit now no because it isn't
anybody excuse no nothing change thank
you
you cannot say too wide too far to your
against Africa but they keep doing that
yeah no it's just like a look a
prosecutor represent the community and
when you prosecute someone connected get
okay you connecting a community is more
or less homogeneous when you represent
the world there's so many voices there's
seven billion voices in fact so it's
complicated but it's growing it's moving
what do you think the future will be for
the ICC you know for me let's see for
the world the one need less produced
system imagine if someone but steal your
bike and yes no police and no judge what
you do you had to fight with the
neighbor to recover the bike or just
ignore he's stealing your bag and
tomorrow another bike so institutions
are the systems that we invented to
manage violence why there's no war
between Massachusetts and Alabama now
it's impossible because you have the US
government the federal government when
Hal would call when their own Germany
was unified with a famous meeting a
European Union when Helmut Kohl in those
days the leader of Germany say I am
aware that I am using the Hitler Chur
but no one was afraid because the
pannier knows an institution who will
avoid him a
they contribute in Germany and France so
basically we can understand to tell some
basic piece it's not just about killing
the bad guys it's about building
institutions and it's complicated but
that's that's why I like to be at Yale
so now you are at Yale here at the
Jackson Institute as a senior fellow
teaching students what is it that you'd
like them to take away from your class I
don't know theories I know what is
happening real life and another one like
this
Jackson approach to a people like me who
were coming with the reality and we need
that we need that we the new facts that
was my my challenge to transform my
experience into information that Scola
can transform into theory that is my
challenge
another one trying to do and the way I
found nearly very collegial and my the
problem is look I was trying to be
predictable when I was a prosecutor I
prepare threose plans so I present my
next three-year plan so when I was in
the last two thousand nine thousand
twelve I called a friend of mine who is
a Stanford University and say look can
you collect your friends because I
thought with the Hoover Institute people
very smart okay I got to see what they
are thinking on this issue can I go
there for one day and interview your
guys to see if they have some ideas okay
I will do it but no hopes you say really
yeah and he's funny I went there I'm a
Nobel Prize guy telling me oh I'm very
glad to meet you because my students
always talk about the SEC I try to
dissuade them but they insist can you
explain to me what is this why they are
insisting so much hmm so the other day I
told my friend Stephen Stephen graduate
the great guy is a genius I said your
friend had no idea what happened he said
Louise we are professors we need data
and the data is coming from the 90s
not yet what happened to the 21st
century and interesting because in
particulars even social science we like
quantitative data but who has finished
one case so there's no what that they
because it's a change yeah so that's why
what I'm doing at Jackson is trying to
do a case study because I feel I believe
okay it's important to have quarter data
now LDV percent
the dimension of the problems in one
case that Africa is and then you can see
the interaction between Security Council
who decide to justice first then and
this was consensus then divisions when
decided to use armies in media option in
in Libya and then the consequence city
today so Syria in part it's a
consequence of Libya and I think we have
to understand what is happening in the
last three years to help but the leaders
to understand how they can manage does
intend to do here okay very good
this has been fascinating thank you so
much for being here with us and sharing
some of your work thank you minute for
more information about mr. Moreno Ocampo
please visit our website at yale.edu
slash macmillan report be sure to join
us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale